you'd expect that there would be a
little healthy competition between Brad
Pit and Tom Cruz even so they combined
their powers to make 1994's Oscar
nominated Interview with the Vampire
while pits Lewis and Cruz's lat were
Blood Brothers on screen it doesn't
appear like the same sentiment was
shared when the camera stopped rolling
pit has gone on record to discuss how
generally unhappy he was during the
shoot for the movie according to Radar
Online pit supposedly said he bugged me
there came a point during filming when I
started really resenting him he's North
Pole I'm South he's always coming at you
with a handshake whereas I may bump into
you there was this underline competition
that got in the way of any real
conversation before pit and Cruz wrapped
up Interview with the Vampire there was
a point when the former tried to depart
the project before finding out the
financial impact it would have in the
end he stayed on but he and Cruz have
largely remained out of each other's
orbit since then